[Music]
now to the cover story of this week's
magazine
journalist ian williams takes a detailed
look at the cosy relationship between
cambridge university
and the chinese communist party arguing
that china has bought the university
to make his case he joins the show now
and we're also joined by professor kerry
brown director of the lao china
institute at king's college london
ian can you explain what's happened
between cambridge and china
yeah the biggest project that cambridge
has
out the international project is a joint
venture with nat with nanjing
municipal authority in china which is
described as a smart
cities research center this was signed
in 2019
and has been valued by cambridge at 10
million pounds
now this is we are told
um research into the bold new technology
that will make cities more livable going
forward
sensors that will determine everything
from when your rubbish needs to be
cleared through to the flow of traffic
now certainly this may happen and it may
well be that the brave
urban centers of the future are fully
connected but
in chinese terms smart cities
are called safe cities and it's
inextricably linked with surveillance
technology
security and repression epitomized by
what's happening in xinjiang
and to me it's incredibly naive that
cambridge can
pursue what is the biggest project of
its type and the only one which has its
name
in a technology which in the chinese
terms
is contributing to the surveillance
state and
to repression in that country um this
the contract itself was celebrated by
the oversight
people at cambridge whose job it is to
to examine these sorts of deals as just
the sort of
relationship that china that are
cambridge needed going forward now that
britain has left the european
union and there seemed to be no serious
discussion
about how this technology could be
contained
and how technology which is clearly dual
use
could be prevented from being used
repressively
as it has been quite widely within china
kerry what do you think is all of this
above board or not
well the first thing i have to say is
i'm a graduate at cambridge so i have to
declare that interest the second is
i have known um the institute at jesus
college and i've spoken there and i've
known peter nolan for
oh 25 years um and his
uh interest in you know kind of china's
politics and
his you know kind of sympathy i suppose
is uh not a new thing it's been around
for 25 years
i mean cambridge university's governance
has been
highly secretive for 700 years
and i have to say there's one
organization on the planet that is more
opaque than the communist party of china
that's cambridge university
uh so i mean i think that's one of the
issues the second
other associated issue is that
i i think you know it's right for ian to
raise these concerns
um the issue really though is that of
course british universities
generally and for quite some time have
needed to be very entrepreneurial school
of
economics got into terrible problems
with gaddafi in the you know kind of
early 2000s and
one of the issues is on the one hand we
have a government that tells us you know
go
raise money be entrepreneurial post
brexit on the other
we uh kind of tell we'll be terribly
careful with the world's second biggest
economy even though there may be very
important alignments
those alignments are really really
crucial too public health
environment these are not issues where
china needs to be opaque or anyone needs
to be opaque because we all seem to now
know what we're dealing with
and i think it's really important to
maintain lines of engagement
i look upon it as you know it's probably
problematic that you might have parts of
british universities
that need to have engagement and
dialogue with parts of the chinese
entity and state that are problematic
but i think that engagement needs to go
ahead
and i think that it is relatively low
risk the issue is that
jesus college crew one of these china
centers
is doing engagement in an area which is
difficult
it's well observed it's being watched by
journalists and observers
and i don't see it as quite as grave an
issue as buying a whole university
the final thing i have to say is that um
the xinjiang issue
is a serious and important issue i don't
deny that
that is not however the situation in
other areas of china the problem really
is that
for the chinese middle class who are
absolutely crucial to the xi jinping
leadership
their views too are often public opinion
as far as we can see from what evidence
anecdotally and also
in terms of uh you know kind of surveys
we're pretty supportive of maybe even
more extreme positions
and so we can't just blame one
organization for this
the communist party of china can take
some of the flat for sure and should
take some of the flat
but it is not as simple as just saying
that organization
is the only problem it's much more
complicated
well there's a lot to impact there
carrie because you touched on a lot of
the things that i want to touch on in
this conversation
in general ian just just starting with
one of the factors which is that
surely some engagement with china
especially on a research basis
has to be done for one there are some
research that is just
a bit more innocuous for example climate
you mentioned this renewable energies
institute that cambridge also has a
partnership
with china on and especially on a
material basis you know if the
government is
going to be cutting research funding and
stephen tube the vice chancellor of
cambridge himself
has campaigned to not get against these
research cuts then you know they've got
to get their money somewhere
for our stem subjects so what do you say
to that
they have but i think it needs to be
transparent and it needs to be open
and it needs to be debated and as kerry
pointed out
too often and we're seeing this with
cambridge that this has not been the
case
and they preferred to sweep any to avoid
any sort of discussion or sweep these
sort of arguments under the table
i mean two examples i used in the
article
was the engineering department at
cambridge that signed this
quantum computer deal with tencent
the owner of uh wechat and
the blurb on the engineering department
website i checked it it was not only
um termed in ways which would
justify it from a wechat point of view
but it was lifted from the wechat
website website
um likewise i think with the institutes
at jesus college when they were first
set up
um which was in the wake of the the
golden era
of cameron and osborne which was you
know very much like a starting gun
for everyone to go chasing after chinese
money almost no
no questions asked the language on their
websites was also lifted almost word for
word
from communist party documentation from
from from propaganda
and i do accept that there is the need
for engagement but i think it has to be
done
in an open and transparent way i mean
the example i i
made in the piece um the sustainability
leadership center
in cambridge the refurbishment of the
old post office
now this is a very important issue
renewable energy
but half of the almost 13 million pound
cost of that refurbishment is being met
by a chinese entrepreneur
now nowhere in the chai in the
literature put forward by cambridge
the glowing description of this
particular character does it mention
that he's a member of the
chinese parliament and the communist
party advisory group
and indeed when the deal was being
signed on this center
this same body the npc was busy passing
a law
that effectively shut down the remnants
of democracy in hong kong
and surely we should know that that
we're not
that cambridge is not just getting money
from a billionaire
who is into renewable energy which is
you know
commendable though that might be but it
is also accepting money from somebody
who is a party
to repression in hong kong and i think
if that were known a lot of people may
feel rather less comfortable about it
kerry ian mentions you know
entrepreneurs and
companies like tencent who are primari
primarily tech companies and wechat is a
social media platform
uh as well as the ccp do you think that
any money that comes from china
can ever be clean in the way that we
would like it to be given
just how interventionist the communist
party is in everyday life
in china i mean money coming from
anywhere is going to be problematic
what's clean money i mean that's an
interesting concept to me
it must be a relative term there must be
more money that's cleaner cleaner than
others
well um i mean if you so if you say
uh that china is problematic because of
lack of transparency uh
because of entrepreneurs being deeply
linked to the
uh party state um and i mean that's true
i mean we cannot
deny that you know there are links
although i think they're complicated and
not straightforward
you then have to say okay we don't deal
with china period you can't have an
intermediary position you either deal or
you don't deal
and my point is that um
maybe the the the only big disagreement
i have with the ian's analysis i suppose
is that i don't think we can do much
about the problem there china has
many other places to look at and many
other things to do
it is on its way to being the world's
biggest economy and
that looks most unlikely not to stop for
us
it's going to be a really interesting
question about organizations like
cambridge university that
prioritize rightly uh the freedom of
their associated institutions colleges
and different departments
who will if if we want the level of
transparency that dean's alluding to
they're going to have to radically
exchange the way that they communicate
with each other the way that they deal
with each other
cambridge university as an institution
cannot really do much about what a
college institution like the china
center does
that's its autonomy that's it's a
freedom that's what's been the case for
700 years
and so if you want to change that you
have to change the governance of
cambridge university to have that
openness the problem is here it's not
really in china on that
at that level and i don't really know
how you do that because their autonomy
is really important for themselves the
issue that china has raised
is really more for us to deal with
within ourselves
and it's going to be a very very tough
thing because in essence what you're
going to end up arguing is
we are needing to be more subject to
regulations and rules
and government interference because of
china
which is a very interesting thing that
china the great surveillance problem
means that we then surveil ourselves
much more well that's win-win for china
i guess
ian what do you think um well i i think
it just needs more rigorous
oversight i don't necessarily would
characterize it that way
but what i would say is that there is a
contrast that when you look at a lot of
the
the research that china is keen on and
is supporting and
and is keen to be part of in the uk you
know
china targets quite clearly i mean it
knows what it needs and what it wants
then is what is going to be useful to it
what it lacks at home and i think it is
quite calculating
and it is quite targeted um
and it it sees in an institution like
cambridge
an organization which alludes to all
these ideas of of
academic freedom um is
also acting like a commercial entity
and it's very good at taking advantage
of that i i think
that china has been very smart it knows
what it wants out of these relationships
and it goes after it
and i don't i think that sometimes when
i talk about
naivety in academia i don't think a lot
of these institutions fully appreciate
just how good china is at this and just
how calculating they can be
when there is a piece of research or a
piece of technology
or a relationship that they want to
develop and i i think
that sometimes in these institutions
these colleges they
they don't really know what they're
dealing with well just to push it sorry
just to push back there though
from what you've said it seems it's
particularly what they're looking for
that you've got an understanding of it
and
it'll be pretty easy therefore to deal
with this and just say here the areas of
risk
be careful about those and other areas
engage i mean i think this sounds very
soluble
it should be i think you're right for
you what are the areas of engagement and
what are the areas of risk because as
kerry says a lot of money from china
is inextricably linked to the chinese
communist party so if that link in and
off itself makes the money
unacceptable compromising where are the
areas in which you can accept chinese
partnership or money or research
i think there are areas that kerry
mentioned like climate change like clean
energy
a lot of areas where there are our
mutual concern
but i would start from a position of
extreme skepticism
um when i'm examining some of this
proposed investments and some of these
proposed
link-ups i mean don't forget we're we're
dealing with a situation here where
you know it's not a question of will
some of this or could some of this
technology end up being used
for military or repressive purposes by
law
civilian developments must be used or
must be made available
available to the security state um there
are
several laws which which mandate this
it's not uh
so much will it happen it has to happen
by law and i think
i would start from a position of extreme
skepticism
yes there are areas where we need to
cooperate and yes universities are
businesses that are in need of money
um but i would start with a very
skeptical approach but
i do accept as kerry was saying that it
should be
it should be uh not easy but it
shouldn't be difficult to lay out
parameters as to what
should be allowed and what should not be
allowed um but there are at the same
time a lot of gray areas
kerry do you think this is a problem
facing other universities in the uk and
indeed around the world
yeah i mean i think that we as
universities
obviously are going into very uncertain
economic
climate with lots of issues european
students it's not going to be easy for
them to come to the uk because of brexit
that's just a fact
and chinese students are coming in
greater numbers
and you know that is important to
remember i think those chinese students
are coming for
purely educational reasons but it means
that universities are accused of you
know
uh kind of doing things because they
have so many you know kind of interest
from china
um i think it's important to have
consensus though through discussions
like this
on areas where it is permissible and
good to engage with china
uh china is a technical innovator now
technological innovator it's
something like 637 billion us dollars
goes into research development a year
way more than probably the rest of the
world and
it's going to increase seven percent i
think year on year for the next five
years
many of those areas maybe are very big
problems artificial
intelligence is a big big problem but
the quandary is that china is going to
be now producing for the first time in
modern history
really interesting technology that would
probably
help us hugely and so we have to really
think through the cost of saying right
we're not going to deal with you here
it might be very right not to deal with
china for sure i mean i'm not saying we
should but there will be more and more
opportunity costs
and in environment i think china we have
to work with china we have to have
universities work with china and i think
the
uh final thing i say is that some of the
charming brand building that some of our
politicians have been going in you know
about
beating up china and all this stuff i
don't know they obviously haven't
thought through this very deeply because
it's not straightforward i think ian's
right there's areas where we've got to
work there's areas where we can't work
we need an honest transparent debate
with ourselves about where those areas
are
and then i think we'll be okay and
finally ian how much of
it is down to the british government to
do in terms of whether or not
providing more stem funding so that
china doesn't have to be there
to fill in the gaps on technological
research or in terms of
education about china we hear a lot
about confucius institutes which are
highly controversial but i see very
little else places that young bright
students can go to study
chinese or learn about china if it's not
for with a chinese sponsored
place so you know maybe should the
british government be doing better on
that point
i think they could be doing a lot better
because uh
we haven't really had okay there's this
talk about guidelines for universities
guidelines for
research but i still see a very confused
china policy coming out of this
government it doesn't really
know what it wants this is from
everything from where we want to condemn
we want to talk up talk out politically
but it should be business and
investment as usual well you know i'm
not convinced you can separate that but
you could also extend that
into the university sector we see a lot
of statements
coming out of government about the need
to look more closely
at cooperation and collaboration with
with china
but we don't hear a lot about where
other sources
of funding might come from were other
means of
as you said the example you sight of of
of learning
about the chinese language outside of
confucius institutes
so it's not a very joined up policy you
know we do hear a lot about what they
don't want
as kerry said there is a lot of um
a lot of rhetoric comes out but but i
wouldn't describe it particularly as a
policy
ian williams and kerry brown thanks for
joining spectator tv now to read
articles like ian williams's every week
you can pick up the issue of the
spectator or get a subscription for it
you can get 12 weeks off the spectator
for just 12 pounds if you go to
spectator dot co dot uk
forward slash tv offer and remember
we'll also throw in that 20 pound amazon
gift voucher
and if you enjoyed this episode of
spectator tv why not subscribe to our
youtube channel for free so you never
miss an episode
just click the subscribe button at the
bottom of this video and the bell icon
to make sure
thanks for watching and do join us again
next week when football will have come
[Applause]
home
[Applause]
[Music]